die gartensaison ist noch nicht vorbei
deswegen schnappt euch eure samentütchen
und dann machen wir unsere oktober
aussagen zusammen
und wir starten mal wieder mit der
anzucht in unseren köpfen das kann man
jetzt noch ein gewächshaus machen oder
im haus und ich sehe jetzt noch mal eine
runde spinat aus da sehe ich die sorte
winter riesenschreck strich werde das
ist die sorte mit den zwei namen da gebe
ich jetzt in jedes töpfchen zweisam
reihen einfach falls einer nicht aufgeht
und bedeckte wieder werde danach
angießen nicht vergessen dafür ist
wieder die wahl brause am start die
verlinke ich euch auch wieder in der
video beschreibung ist ganz cool weil
die feinen samen dann nicht so verklemmt
werden
eine andere tolle spinat sollte wer die
sorte matador wie bei euch auch richtig
gerne an die beiden sorten sind sehr
ähnlich wenn ihr eine davon bekommt
würde ich dir auf jeden fall nehmen es
gibt unterschiedliche sorgen je nachdem
ob man die im sommer oder im winter
anbauen möchte es wichtig dass man jetzt
für den winter eben die sorten anbaut
die auf frost besser wegstecken können
dann machen wir weiter mit dem besten
salat unter diesem himmel das ist der
backe ich sende euch auch immer die
sortennamen nochmal ein weil da fragen
immer alle hilfen wie schreibt man das
ist französisch und das ist ein salat
der den ganzen winter über sehr sehr
tapfer allen temperaturen trotzt und dem
man den ganzen winter über beenden kann
und den ziehe ich jetzt auch vor das
sind meine letzten samen in dem tütchen
und dieses jahr hat es so viel geregnet
da es alle samen die ich von meinen
pflanzen ernten wollte einfach
weggewaschen wurden richtig ärgerlich
also wenn ihr irgendwo sagt wird von der
sorte bekommt dann zuschlagen weil die
ständig ausverkauft und wenn ihr die
möglichkeit habt ihr im garten selber
weiter zu vermehren dann macht das auf
jeden fall salat ist ein licht kein mana
denken sie darf man nicht mit erde
bedecken die zusammenstöße ich einfach
nur auf ich habe die erde falschen
angefeuchtet und dann drücke ich die so
anders da immer noch nicht dran kommt
machen wir weiter mit dem posten
das ist ein sehr milder winter salat
kann man jetzt auch vorziehen zum
beispiel fürs gewächshaus oder den
freeway kasten könnt ihr auch im
freiland dann raus pflanzen und der hat
auch ganz feine samen deswegen ist da
die brause echt von vorteil versteuert
sich immer so ein paar samen hier um das
loch ein und drückt die dann wieder an
hast du deinen schmeckt nach nicht viel
ist aber super gesund ohne tolle
ergänzung für den salatteller im winter
so jetzt könnt ihr auch noch feldsalat
im haus vorziehen den sehe ich aber
direkt ins bild aber falls eure beete
jetzt noch belegt sind dann noch andere
gemüse wachsen dann könnt ihr den in
töpfchen vorziehen und dann später dahin
pflanzen wenn der platz frei geworden
ist aber machen wir mal weiter mit dem
ganzen die man jetzt direkt ins beet
sehen kann
wir legen los mit mangold und da sind
ein kunden sorten mix weil das eben
ziemlich cool aussieht am ende im beet
schaut mal der gelbe stile und
orangefarbene pinkl ich glaube auch rote
und das sieht am ende richtig richtig
toll aus dass es jetzt im oktober
sowieso ganz ganz wichtig dass ihr daran
denkt immer den wetterbericht im auge zu
behalten damit gemerkt wenn der erste
frost angekündigt ist und dann
gegebenenfalls die empfindlicheren
gemüse vor frost schützen könnte indem
wir zum beispiel ein winter schutzvlies
über den ausbreitet oder einen mini
tunnel aufbaut dann könnt ihr jetzt auch
asia salat sehen das ist ein richtig
forster richtig richtig scharfer winter
salat ein asiatisches gemüse das kann
man sowohl frisch essen als auch einfach
mit in der gemüsepfanne packen ist eine
richtig coole abwechslung mal für den
winter und da gibt es auch coole sorten
mixe mit dunkelroten und grünen blättern
und unterschiedlichen formen macht sich
richtig schön im beet radieschen kann
man ja auch fast rund ums jahr sehen und
weil ich dieses bild hier sowieso später
mit einem vlies abdecke es ist jetzt
noch nicht zu spät für die deswegen
kommen die jetzt auch in die erde
ist auch eine tolle sache finde ich wenn
man mit kindern gärtnert weil die so
schnell wachsen das ist eigentlich
wahrscheinlich das schnellstwachsende
gemüse im ganzen garten
ich traue sich jetzt einmal hier aus
nämlich ein paar vielen gestreut damit
erde bedecken und gut angießen und den
spinal zähle ich als auch direkt ins
beet haben ihn ja eben auch schon in der
anzucht gehabt aber ich will das oft ein
bisschen praktischer gerade wenn man
viel davon anbauen möchte das einfach
direkt ins beet zu sehen aber denkt
daran alle 15 die wir in der anzucht
eben hatten sie könnte jetzt auch direkt
nach draußen inspizient da habe ich auch
wieder die gleiche sollte wie eben in
der anzucht also die sorte verdi winter
wiesen oder matador das sind richtig
gute sorten tipps den winter salat und
den feldsalat und die post so lang könnt
ihr jetzt also auch direkt ins beet
aussehen es gibt eine erbsen sollte die
man jetzt aussehen kann dann wächst die
vor dem winter schon ein bisschen hoch
und man kann sie relativ früh nächstes
jahr so ungefähr im mai ernten also
früher als die erbsen wie man erst im
frühling aussehen würde weil die eben
diesen wachstumsvorsprung hat das ist
die winter erbse sima ist eine richtig
tolle sache also wenn ihr noch irgendwo
platz habt und wenn ihr auf ersten steht
dann könnt ihr das mal ausprobieren und
jetzt vor dem winter noch erbsen
aussehen habt ihr schonmal ersten triebe
probiert das sind einfach triebe von
ersten pflänzchen die ungefähr so hoch
sind die sind richtig süß schmecken
irgendwie lustig so ein bisschen auch
wie frische erbsen es ist total lecker
und eine super möglichkeit um im winter
noch mehr aus dem eigenen garten ernten
zu können dafür könnt ihr jetzt auch
einfach irgendwelche erbsen direkt ins
beet aussehen in dem vorbild kannst mir
ins gewächshaus wo ihr lustig seit ich
nehme dafür jetzt einfach mal so ne mark
erst sie hier man kann auch zuckererbsen
dafür nehmen denn dann schneidet man die
einfach immer wieder oben ab die wachsen
auch wieder nach und kann die mit in den
salat tun oder mit eine gemüsepfanne das
ist echt total erkauft eine sache die
ich jetzt noch ausprobieren werde ist
ich werde jetzt noch blumenkohl direkt
ins gewächshaus sehen und dann mal
schauen ob ich den vielleicht nächstes
jahr ganz früh ernten kann ich habe auch
schon blumenkohl pflänzchen vorgezogen
und ins gewächshaus gepflanzt damit die
da überwintern und nächstes jahr ganz
frühe erste ernte abwerfen aber ich
probiere das jetzt auch noch mal aus in
dem ich dem dunkel einfach direkt rein
sehe ich hab das wie gesagt noch nie
gemacht aber wenn ihr lust habt das mal
mit mir auszuprobieren dann seid ihr
hiermit herzlich eingeladen kommen wir
zu dem gemüse pflanzen die man jetzt
raus pflanzen können wenn man zb gemüse
im haus vorgezogen hat oder auf dem
wochenmarkt pflänzchen gekauft hat und
da könnt ihr natürlich alle gemüse die
bisher in dem ganzen video vorgekommen
sind jetzt auch nach draußen ins beet
pflanzen das ist bei denen allen gar
kein problem was jetzt auch noch sehr
sehr wichtig ist dass man daran denkt
ist zb der knoblauch knoblauch kann man
jetzt im oktober richtig gut stecken der
wächst auch vor dem winter noch ein
stückchen und hat dann im nächsten jahr
einen wachstumsvorsprung man kann den
auch noch mal im frühjahr stecken aber
auch walnuss alarm aber ich sag euch die
pflänzchen die im frühling erst steckt
die wir nie so dicke knollen bilden wie
die die ihr jetzt im herbst steckt und
die dann diesen wachstumsvorsprung haben
ich packe euch mal ein video unten in
die video beschreibung wo ich euch genau
zeige wie ihr knoblauch pflanzen könnt
ihr könnt aber auch wenn ihr nicht auf
die knollen aus leid sondern auf dass
knoblauch grün jetzt knoblauch pflanzen
das klappt ganz genauso in dafür lernte
tier dann einfach den grünen teil der
dann in ein paar wochen oben aus dem
boden raus schaut dass knoblauch grün
schmeckt ein bisschen milder als jetzt
seine ziele stecken würde aber ist eine
super ergänzung um im winter auch noch
mehr aus dem garten ernten zu können und
genauso wie den knoblauch könnt ihr
jetzt auch winterspeck zwiebeln stecken
da geht's auch wieder darum dass man
einen wachstumsvorsprung hat und eine
tolle winter stück zwiebel sorte ist die
sorte radar ansonsten kann man jetzt
auch kartoffeln pflanzen das hat sich
ein bisschen verrückt an aber ich hab
das letztes jahr ausprobiert und das hat
richtig gut geklappt um auch wieder
nächstes jahr eine frühere ernte zu
bekommen wenn ihr wissen wollt was es
damit auf sich hat und wie das
funktioniert dann schaut gerne da
trieben vorbei ansonsten geht raus macht
die welt ein bisschen grüner und wir
sehen uns nächste woche am samstag um 10
4 ein neues video teams